I think it was her like heckling yeah
no turning back now yeah no turning back
down too late too late they put your
name on the Marquee it's too late it's a
done deal you're in Times Square today
oh that's huge
[Music]
I asked you last week what was the last
thing that or what did you and Ryan say
when you last walked out together she
said to me I think I'm gonna lose that
I'm going to return that I actually I
said to him I think I'm gonna lose it
but I actually turned to him and I said
I'm gonna punch you no I said I looked
at him and I said this really sucks did
Ryan give anything a Memento a Keepsake
to pass the torch along besides the milk
obvious beautiful no and a beautiful
photograph he Ryan Seacrest is all class
yeah we basically have been texting each
other all weekend and he was asking me
should I wake up early and watch the
live feed and I said
you should sleep in like a normal human
being I can't I mean I was I said to him
if you don't sleep in I'm gonna be very
angry with you you can watch it anytime
literally we should do a segment where
we wake up Ryan oh he should be the
on-air caller in the morning
great idea there's so many best friends
families yeah
and Lola front and center I know she's
always front and center she made a way
in here I was very excited to see so
many uh close friends and family and
have an audience today which is really
yeah it was really nice it was really
nice so Lola was repping the kids what
did the kids make of mom and dad doing
this full time I don't necessarily know
that the other two even know today is
Mark's first day Michael works a lot and
he works very long out he's in college
you know out of state so there are
definitely you know one sleeping for
sure yeah okay if you had one kid to
take over or fill in for you guys well
one of you is away who would it be would
it be Lola Lola Consuelos would be great
Lola would be great but Michael really
wants the gig you know Michael once
again I think he says he wants the gig
because he's not done it but he would be
good at it so he's he's amazing yeah
well too bad Michael yeah Mark's got the
game what was one thing that made you
most nervous about taking over the state
Mark
um it's the number one show in daytime
and don't want to screw that up
um so you know when a team wins a
championship the only place to go is you
know they you just want to keep winning
championships so I just want to be
hopefully value added to the show well
you got your a team here and Kelly Ripa
that's correct you know what I mean by
Tom Brady yeah you're Tom Brady exactly
I'm hardly the coach okay
you guys
there's no separation
preparation of International
professionals so how are you going to
keep things fresh for the you know the
host chats and then how are we going to
keep things like you're going to leave
work at work we have very uh different
um interests outside of work and outside
of our marriage the things that we do on
a hobby level on a skill level are so
vastly different like what she knits I
don't no you don't I do I do yeah we're
speaking about Hobbies yeah and he's
like he's a cyclist he's got he's on a
cycling team
um and so our interests are very
different we we've always worked
together in some capacity we run a
production company together we start on
a soap opera together
private then
we were on a sitcom together we've
always had different jobs together but
this is just like a daily talk show but
that's sort of like we won't go home and
like discuss oh what should we talk
about tomorrow because that's not how we
do things here it's more of a
spontaneous discussion between two
people that have had a full day outside
of just discussing host chat we'll see
we'll we'll split off right after this
and I'll see you at dinner time so if
you want to see me at dinner time
because I'm working on the game show
tonight yeah yeah yeah will there be
anything that is off limit sure yeah
what's up limits
she's very good I think it'll change
from day to day yeah yeah it'll change
from video Kelly is there anything for
you that's awful event of course not
nothing is ever off or an open yes I'm
an open book and if you don't read me
fast enough I'll read me myself out loud
to you
you guys did meet what 30 years ago on
All My Children almost yeah incredible
so
so that job compared to this one are you
seeing what worked and what didn't work
then those hours were much longer those
were 12 hour days those were you know
every day every day
um we had we decided to move out of the
city when we got married and we lived in
New Jersey and we drove we commuted
together and come in and out of the city
those were it was our big experiment
yeah a big experiment so if you guys can
make it through a commute into the city
then you got it we didn't it didn't last
long it didn't last long and finally how
did you prepare my obviously Mark you've
been here you've been along for the
journey for how many years now here at
live I mean Mark's been filling in here
I've been here for almost 23 years he's
been filling in for that long so it's
been a long time you told me just to be
myself yeah enjoy the moment
um one show at a time just like we
always do you can't overthink it it's
just a live TV show
[Music]
thank you